hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt bei
mir geht es heute einen indischen reis
denn wir haben ja morath indische woche
ja das gibt es heute einen raise und
zwar kann man ihn ganz gut als beilage
zu anderen hauptgerichten servieren
ich zeig euch erfahren aber kostet
zutaten ich habe hier 375 gramm was
marty reiße ich brauche drei esslöffel g
oder butterschmalz ich habe ich noch
gewürze und zwar 15 teelöffel senf
ferner einen halben teelöffel curcuma
das jetzt bereits gemahlen 12 curry
blätter eine halbe zimtstange und vier
ganz selten habe ich fünf karton kapsel
und zwei chilis wasser chili nach bedarf
und nach geschmack 15 teelöffel salz 6
150 milliliter wasser
ich habe ich noch koriander eine limite
und etwas pfeffer zuerst einmal nehme
ich jetzt den reis und muss den unter
klarem wasser abwaschen und zwar
gespannt den reis ist so lange bis das
wasser und unklar auskommt damit will
wäscht man einfach die stärke heraus
jetzt gebe ich das butterschmalz in
einen topf und erhitzt ist also normale
butter kann man nicht nehmen also
normalerweise nimmt magie und das ist
einfach geklärte butter normales wetter
alles auf verbrennen und butterschmalz
ja auch geklärt deswegen geht es
jetzt kommen die ganzen gewürze mit uns
butterschmalz außerdem die schotten die
brauche ich später erst
die habe ich jetzt ganz kurzen mit
angebratenen jetzt kommt direkt der
einst mit rein wird auch kurz angebraten
wie ihr seht dann was sich alles gut
vermischt hat wenn der reis komplett
geld wird er das koma
sein
das sind 22 freunde okay die zweifler
eine geschichte eine geschichte
zwei freunde zwei freunde schlafen in
einem fremden land in einer fremden
stadt in einem fremden hotel de ag
da stehen sie da stehen sie morgens auf
also ich glaub wir sind indien sagt
daher wie kommst du darauf sagt mal raus
da ist eine toilette am ende des ganges
dass der see
der fluss der durch indien fließen
geografie war nicht so einfach nicht so
meine stärke aber dann war da wird am
ende des ganges toilette ok ich lass mal
lieber ich gewiss noch das alles mit 3
den reis aufkochen und dann darf der so
etwa 10 minuten kochen bei geschlossenem
deckel aber ich lasse es erst mit
geöffnetem deckel aufkochen dann kommt
der deckel drauf ich schalte hitze
runter und dann darf es etwa 10 minuten
köcheln
der reiz ist jetzt gekocht und ich gebe
immer ganz gern noch ein bisschen
küchenpapier ein wenn ich merke dass der
reis einfach noch zu feucht ist
das zieht nämlich die feuchtigkeit in
den weg zum abschmecken und nehmen dafür
die limette da fehlt nämlich noch ein
bisschen säure
ich sage das ganze ich richtig zur ruhe
sally politik da kommt jetzt noch etwas
limettensaft mit rein
zum abrunden des geschmacks
ich finde einfach schon die farbe des
kreises richtig genial also kurkuma
gehört nicht zu meinen lieblingen in der
küche
jetzt auch die chilischoten die werde
ich jetzt fein hacken und dann kann ich
den reis auch schon sanieren
wenn ich den reis direkt serviert also
bei uns gibt's denn jetzt nicht alleine
so pur sondern da gibt es eine
hauptspeise mit dazu ich mache das immer
ganz so was kommt inter fans gefäß ich
mag es nicht nur rosinen drin sind er
hat noch gar keine rosinen sein
nicht so aber ich finde das wird hier
sogar neun geschmack ich wirklich gut
das macht es nicht
der teller drauf
da kommt natürlich noch mit den chili
mit drauf ich glaube du magst nicht so
viel technik kann im juli seien nur
keinen rosin und etwas koriander
also du darfst den reiz einfach mal so
probieren aber die bekommt er gleich das
hauptgericht hat so okay dass man
richtig toll so aus wie gesagt ich
probiere jetzt mal jetzt natürlich
bedenken denn reise ist man ja nicht so
als beilage ein bisschen salz noch und
ich mache hat noch ein bisschen sauer
aber deutschen pop super dann ist jetzt
nicht ganz auf den gleich gibt's bei uns
eingekauft weise dazu ich bin da halt
auf jeden fall eine richtig tolle farbe
die senfkörner stehen natürlich nicht
nur hübsch aussehen und schmecken auch
richtig genial da drin
und falls ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt geht auf cds - blog.de da steht
noch mal ganz genau
und ja ich finde ich ganz viel spaß beim
nachkochen und sehen das nächste mal
wieder biss dann wahrscheinlich alle
kinder mitsingen hat jetzt ist nicht
auch gleich hauptspeicher so